22 winners all underage 20 $100,000 to
drop out of school and pursue our dreams
this is team Technorati
each of the teal houses has a name our
house is the decent shop house which
means the house of science the German
flags or kind of a joke my home is an
absolutely magnificent place I live in a
house with two biochemists a
bioinformatics issed
a hardware hacker so we have quite a
diverse set of people here this is the
movie room which I share with my house
we usually don't actually watch movies
or TV instead we talk about new
discoveries and read papers on the
screen there's a computer there and it's
mainly just used for browsing the
internet this is my little safe space I
would say pictures of everything because
my parents are freaking out and
concentrating on things which I really
need to work on because I I think I
really have a very very I have a deficit
comes like focusing I like to have my
dues visible because I find that far
more motivating and so I've broken it
down into my self-improvement section I
have the developing my math and physics
intuition section I have very low
priority section the done section and of
course the goals for today my project
has changed insufficient I was
previously working on assisted mobility
technology and then I thought to myself
why am i working on assistive mobility
what I can completely replace biological
functionality in example I think grasp
and my neuroprosthetic hand leads the
signal sees that I wanted to grasp and
moves the appropriate joint angles I am
working on making a neural prosthetics
learn more diverse set of actions more
quickly by adjusting their algorithms
I have many side projects and one of
those side projects is this pure
mathematics project I'm currently
reading a book on applied algebraic
systems in actuality categories and sets
are very different Oh
or I could talk about the Collatz
conjecture
sorry I'm like I want to talk about all
the math we should definitely check out
all the books because they were suppose
be chosen by a designer who designed
everything here so she literally starts
the books by the cover they have like a
bunch of books about business or
starting a startup I guess there's some
subliminal messaging going on right here
the main subject matter actually began
with a face and a birds mask I started
out with painting and I usually sketch
so turning to a mediums such as painters
tape which I have no ability to shade is
quite difficult I would say that the
artistic choices here are mainly focused
around parallelism and keeping as my
friend Chris Walker says symmetry within
the asymmetry this is a toy that I used
to make when I was little in which you
can explore waves this is where my
roommates and I make music together and
sing along Yamaha is a classical guitar
and have a fixed schedule I wake up at a
certain time go to sleep at a certain
time like have these like periods of
time where I'm most creative I can't get
to know that and then work the most
doing those timings so the guitar is
actually part of that I would actually
this is also a haircuts today just like
the furniture today but we can also do
it tomorrow I think hey are they on the
opener there are they open tomorrow
awesome really most of what we eat here
is apples and quite a lot of
it's better be a good burrito I'm never
in a Bree like this is my life do you
feel like you started already or do you
feel like it hasn't set in yet the
movies where I feel like what I'm doing
doesn't sort of matter at all and I get
feel like super crushed but then but I
usually do is I just go and I read like
TechCrunch you know all these other
stuff cuz these people can go out and
like get funding and they speak to
investors and like have a problem out
there why can't I do it and so yeah I've
been given this amazing opportunity I
find that if somebody tells me that
something is too challenging or that I
can't do it I just want to do it more it
gives me more motivation tune in for the
next episode of teen Technorati when we
peer into the future at NASA and be sure
to subscribe to the wired Channel